Patrick bourreau est bouché charcutier à
tour depuis 9 ans dans son atelier de
transformation il fabrique l'authentique
riette de tour à base de quatre morceaux
de porc de Touren bien sûr et il doit
respecter un cahier des charges bien
précis 50 % de poitrine et de d'épaule
et 50 % de jambon et de filet donc voilà
c'est une quantité mais on n'a pas le
droit de mettre plus de 75 % de poitrine
et d'épaules dans les riettes de tour
une fois la viande dshossée et coupée en
carré de 6 par 6 il fait revenir le tout
dans cette marmite avec du seindou de la
graisse de porc pendant une bonne heure
il rajoute du sel du poivre en
respectant strictement le cahier des
charges il faut bien les faire revenir
dès le départ pour les colorer pourant
une heure à peu près et après les faire
laisser migoter pendant 8 à 9h à feu
très doux à une température de 70 à
80°gr 10h plus tard et après avoir
émietté la viande Patrick obtient le
produit final mais le travail n'est pas
fini pour autant il faut remplir la
fiche d'indication géographique protégé
qui reprend point par point les stades
de la fabrication à cause à cause de
l'IGP on est obligé de remplir une
feuille de traçabilité très stricte
parce que bon faut faut respecter tout
ce qui est quantité sur les les viandes
jambon carré filet et épau les poitrines
bien sûr tant de cuisson ingrédients
rajoutés jusqu'à la température tout est
noté sur cette feuille ensuite Patrick
conditionne Hette dép de 250 et 500 g
nous les moulons à chaud 67 de
minimum les rillettes moulé il ne reste
plus qu'à les déguster sur des tranches
de pain grillé avec un verre de Touren
primeur à consommer avec modération bien
[Musique]
sûr